the Kentucky family is demanding answers
today in the death of a frontline health
care worker who was killed during a
police raid two months ago today Brianna
Taylor's family is suing three
Louisville police officers after the 26
year old woman was shot and killed in
her apartment now officials say this
incident back in March was tied to a
drug investigation where police were
searching for someone else as our
national correspondent Jericka Duncan
reports Taylor's mother claims gross
negligence took her daughter's life
Brianna loves life and she loved to help
people and she loved a family she didn't
deserve what they did to her Tamika
Palmer is Breanna Taylor's mother the 26
year old was an EMT working in emergency
rooms at two hospitals and helping
respond to the corona virus outbreak at
home but just after midnight on march
13th police shot Taylor at least eight
times killing her in the apartment she
shared with her boyfriend Kenneth Walker
officers knocked on the door several
times and announced their presence as
police who were there with a search
warrant the officers forced entry into
the exterior door and were immediately
met by gunfire Louisville Metro Police
say the officers were part of a
narcotics investigation and opened fire
after Walker shot first they're now on
administrative reassignment pending the
results of an internal investigation the
lawsuit against the officers claims the
suspect they were searching for was
already in custody Taylor's family
alleges the officers wearing plain
clothes did not identify themselves and
that Walker a registered gun owner was
shooting at men he believed were
breaking in Walker is now charged with
first degree assault an attempted murder
of a police officer they thought they
were being burglarized
the Second Amendment not applied to
african-americans attorney Ben Crump
joined Brianna Taylor's case this week
he is also representing the family of
Ahmad Aubrey who was shot dead in
February while on a run in his Georgia
neighborhood this was a completely
unnecessary and justifiable killing
the innocent one for CBS this morning
Jericka Duncan your heart goes out of
that family they're looking for answers
as to how their daughter was killed and
we hope they get them